[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a escala en París una
emisión de radio Francia internacional
en colaboración con la televisión France
24 en español en la que cada semana
damos la palabra a personas del mundo de
las ciencias las artes los deportes la
política y claro está de la sociedad
civil la actividad de las empresas
mineras en América Latina ha estado
frecuentemente asociada al despojo de
territorios de esas comunidades y a la
intimidación Incluso el asesinato de
Defensores ambientalistas en el caso de
Honduras país de Centroamérica 117 de
esos Defensores fueron asesinados entre
el 2012 y el 2021 y decenas más se
encuentran amenazados de muerte es el
caso de reinaldo Domínguez a quien
recibimos hoy en esta escala en París
reinaldo bienvenido Gracias por
acompañarnos en este programa Muchas
gracias Braulio es un placer compartir
con usted y hablar de estos temas
pues bienvenido es usted originario de
la comunidad de guapinol en el
nororiente de Honduras es en esa Región
donde se encuentra precisamente el
parque nacional montaña de botadero
Carlos escaleras y ahí mismo Existen dos
Ríos El río guapinol el río San Pedro
que pertenecen a la comunidad de ustedes
donde está usted pero también hay una
mina que ha venido a perturbar la
situación usted está de gira para hablar
de esta temática Cuál es el objetivo de
esta gira qué es lo que pretenden con
esta gira que están realizando por la
Unión Europea
el objetivo de esta gira Braulio es
posicionar la lucha porque se estaba
hablando de que con la salida de ocho
Defensores que estuvieron presos por 914
días se creía que se había terminado por
el contrario El segundo paso por darse
está pendiente que es levantar y
suspender esos proyectos de extractiva
extractivos de minería cielo abierto
verdad que fue una promesa de campaña
vamos a hacer un poco de historia para
que nuestro público lo entienda mejor es
es una comunidad donde ustedes viven
donde no había ningún problema con la
tierra en 2014 hay una mina que se
instala es una mina que pertenece a la
empresa encu de capital estadounidense
mayoritariamente De qué se examina y
Cuál ha sido el procedimiento de manera
breve entre el 2014 y ahora
ese Esas dos concesiones que el estado
le otorgó a Lenin Pérez y Ana facusé un
matrimonio hondureño es dióxido de
hierro y es una minería a cielo abierto
en una zona protegida el parque nacional
montaña botaderos Carlos escalera el que
hoy por hoy tiene grandes
impactos medioambientales que ya están
ocurriendo en los ríos fue en 2014
Entonces que se le concede la se le
concede la explotación de la mina en
2018 es cuando ustedes empiezan a tener
problemas y es en ese momento también
cuando un grupo de medioambientalistas
incluido usted van a encontrarse delante
de la justicia es correcto es así es
decir después de un campamento que duró
88 días evitando a la empresa que no
destruyera el parque hubo esa esos
requerimientos para 32 personas
decidimos presentarnos verdad a la
justicia hondureña voluntariamente
porque consideramos que defender el agua
no es delito
justamente reinaldo cuando hablamos de
una empresa minera y lo deseamos en la
introducción Generalmente hay problemas
con el agua Qué ha pasado con el agua
del río guapinol con el agua del río San
Pedro que es de donde están sus comunas
y la presencia de lámina explíquele al
público por favor los ríos están
severamente
sedimentados es decir agua con lodo y el
río San Pedro que lleva más de un año en
esa en esa situación hoy ya un
laboratorio dio por positivo que
está contaminado al menos con un 80% de
metales pesados en este caso hierro
Entonces por lo tanto la minera ha
venido A causar problemas para que la
gente no ya no se siga bañando en el río
ni siga utilizandola Quién va a utilizar
es agua sucia ni los animales la quieren
ciertamente decíamos usted se vio
involucrado por parte de la justicia
hondureña junto con otros
medioambientalistas en un proceso
fueron en un primer momento condenados
la justicia después se desistió y dijo
que no han vuelto de nueva cuenta a
condenarlos ha habido campañas a nivel
internacional amnistía internacional en
el 2020 realizó a nivel internacional
una campaña en defensa de ustedes y del
agua de Honduras de huapinol
concretamente pero hoy en día Cuál es su
situación jurídica
bueno la situación jurídica de nosotros
es que pende de la voluntad de de la
justicia hondureña para reconocer que
realmente defender los bienes no es
delito pero que nos enfrentamos a un
empresario muy fuerte económicamente y
este es capaz de doblegar a la justicia
hondureña y a tener bajo prisión y
amenazas a los defensoras y Defensores
de estos bienes En ese sentido nosotros
creemos que realmente es lamentable que
el sistema judicial nuestro sea tan
débil que no
responda ante las amenazas que tenemos
de nuestros bienes y de los que lo
defiende hay que saber que Honduras se
encuentra como cuarto país en América
Latina Donde ha habido más asesinatos de
Defensores medioambientalistas
notablemente tal vez ustedes lo
recordarán de 2016 el caso de Berta
Cáceres con dirigente de una comunidad
indígena asesinada su autor intelectual
ha sido recientemente a 22 años de
prisión en el caso de usted reinaldo
usted también ha sido amenazado háblenos
de qué se trata esta amenaza quién Y
cuándo esas amenazas Braulio vienen de
decir que somos enemigos del desarrollo
y que nos oponemos y vienen también a
amenazarnos en el sentido de que
nosotros no No necesitamos los ríos Cómo
es eso que no necesitamos los ríos
que venga el desarrollo bienvenido pero
si nos han ido a poner en riesgo a la
población y a querernos desplazar Claro
que estamos haciendo posición
Yo he sido al nivel del país al interior
desplazado por un año junto a otros
compañeros a Juan López Leonel Jordan
Porfirio sort por defender el río pero
quién lo ha amenazado concretamente
Reynaldo aquí es el empresario Lenin
Pérez con su potencia con su dedo que
dice a lo al ministerio público
sígales la la poniéndole imponiendo los
delitos que son falsos Por cierto verdad
yo tengo 34 años de ser delegado de la
palabra de Dios y nunca había conocido
una prisión nunca hasta que se le
ocurrió a Don Leo Pérez acusarnos de
delitos como asociación ilícita verdad e
incendio agravado privación injusta de
la libertad que nunca lo hemos hecho
verdad Porque queremos vivir en la
comunidad tenemos riquezas suficiente y
le apostamos a que nosotros no
necesitamos de minería Cómo ha
reaccionado el gobierno frente a este
tipo de situación hay que recordar la
presidenta la actual presidenta shumara
Castro ganó las elecciones en el 2021 en
la lista de promesas de prioridades que
se fijó el día de sus discurso ella
mencionaba dos que era concretamente la
libertad precisamente para la gente de
guapinol y la prohibición del desarrollo
de la minería así lo ha abierto dónde
están esas promesas hoy en día mire
esta esta campaña de la presidenta fue
enorme y bien vista es decir pusimos
toda la esperanza y no perdemos la
esperanza creo que va a ir dando pasos
tenemos este año que ya lleva diez meses
pero le vamos a dar el próximo año para
que dé el siguiente paso
ella prometió la liberación de los
compañeros de los ocho compañeros libres
están libres están con su familia Pero
no tienen las cartas de libertad
definitiva ojo con eso en cualquier
momento pueden volver a prisión en
cualquier momento Braulio pueden volver
cuando al empresario se le antoja y el
otro paso que está pendiente por darse
es liberar el parque nacional montaña
botaderos y los ríos guapinol y San
Pedro y todas las treinta y cuatro
fuentes de agua que nacen de ahí de
estos proyectos extractivos que son la
muerte y que han están ya siendo la
muerte de los ecosistemas en este
momento por inversión de los pinares y
ecotec reinaldo yo evidentemente
consulté el sitio internet el sitio
oficial de la empresa en cuestión la
empresa encuesta empresas estadounidense
y se lee lo siguiente la empresa es
ejemplo por sus complejos procesos de
calidad su responsabilidad ambiental sus
programas sociales y generación de
empleos el proyecto fue aprobado por los
habitantes de las comunidades del
influencia del proyecto quienes
respaldan el proyecto qué Me puedes
responder a eso qué le responde a la
empresa a usted es que ese es el el la
la lucha que tenemos que no fuimos
consultados por estas por estos
proyectos extractivo y en ese sentido
nosotros queremos dejar claro
que si el proyecto tuviera desarrollo y
fuera de desarrollo no tuviera los ríos
así sucios contaminados no tuviera
contaminado los ríos y no tuviera
también el parque así como lo tiene en
situación de riesgo deshaciéndolo sin
permiso sin licencia ambientales está
operando por eso es que nosotros como
comunidades nos oponemos el desarrollo
que venga que venga bienvenido pero si
va a ponernos en riesgo las aguas que es
un derecho humano que Naciones Unidas lo
tiene como un derecho humano es
inconcebible y le vamos a hacer lucha
cualquier empresario no solo a lenir
Pérez a cualquier empresario que quiera
meter proyectos de esa naturaleza y que
vengan a lastimar el derecho de las
comunidades que con tanto sacrificios
hemos construido nuestras cositas en las
comunidades en el caso de la empresa
enco también se puede leer dicen que hay
una segunda fase que entiendo que ya
casi está terminada y están planteando
en esta segunda fase darle empleo a tres
mil pero Cuántas personas están siendo
afectadas por este proyecto En guapinol
qué buena pregunta Braulio mire estamos
en peligro alrededor de veinte mil
habitantes de ser desplazados por este
tipo de proyecto de 27 comunidades sin
tomar en cuenta el casco urbano de la
ciudad de Tocoa verdad
y mire un artículo reciente de la
periodista Soraya de de Madrid no
pudieron responder unos dicen que
350 empleos otros cuatrocientos y otros
que 200 el dato de tres mil empleos es
ficticio no hay esa cantidad que no nos
vengan con esos cuentos de decir que el
desarrollo viene con esa cantidad de
empleos y hasta muy poquito tres mil
para lastimar a veinte mil personas que
podemos estar en riesgo entiendo que
existe un sistema de protección que se
ha instalado desde hace años allá en
Honduras en el caso de las amenazas como
las que usted ha padecido funciona este
sistema de producción de disculpe
funciona pero tardado tardan más en
hacer análisis de riesgo que en saber
que estamos en alto riesgo como usted lo
dijo ya
en del 2009 al 2000 de 2021
170 verdad Entonces ese sistema de
protección no está funcionando porque si
no hubiera prevenido Y como dice usted
la compañera Berta pasó por acá en esta
gira y con gran de reconocimiento y no
se pudo evitar el asesinato por lo tanto
nosotros verdad estamos en peligro en
riesgo junto a muchas compañeras y
compañeros con la buena voluntad de
defender estos bienes que tanto los
necesitamos y que sin dudas son de
utilidad para la población no solo de
guapinol sino de la población de
Honduras en general estamos llegando ya
al final de esta escala en París no me
queda sino agradecerle a reinaldo
Domínguez representante de la de
guapinold en Honduras su presencia en
esta escala en París reinaldo Gracias
por habernos acompañado Muchas gracias a
usted Braulio a ustedes les damos una
nueva cita la próxima semana aquí en
otra escala en París